(applaudissements)
- Des délégués en extase à
de soccer de la Coupe du monde
entrrorororoatie et le Brésil
bat son plein.
- We are hereJuJuJuJuste à côtés
tirent la sonnette d'alarme
pour éviter que les négociateuct
d'une souris.
- Un rappel à l'ordre
des Autochtones présents à
la conférence, qui conrerererent
que les négociations traînent.
(en anglais)
qui insiste sur l'importance
d'intégrer locococochtones
dans le processus décisionnel,
sans quoi elle craint que
HINDOU OUMAROU IBRAHIM, Prés.,
. . . . Femmes peules autoc. Tcd
- Un accord qui va avoir
un mécanisme où les peuples
considérés comme partie prenants
qui ont les droits de discuter
et de négocier.
- Laissez-nous gitititititititi.
- Même discours de
ce représentant de la communauté
du Lac-Simon, en Abitibi.
Ronald Bsososososososososososose
protégée avant que l'industrie
minière et forestière étendent
leurs tentacules.
RO
Dép. ressources natur. Lac-Simon
- La frustration qu'on a chez
les Premières Nations, c'est
de voir son territoire pillé
viré tout à l'envers.
- Une aire protégée
dans laquelle son peuple sera
durablement les ressources pour
ainsi préserver leuritititité.
- Nous autres, la forêt,
c'est notre maison.
toutes les ressources.
- Le Canada,hôhôhôhôte de
la conférence, dit vouloir
jouer son rôle de leader
STEVEN GUILBEAULT, ministre
fédé l l l l'Environnement
- Une des choses que je vais
faire au cours des prochains
à insuffler un certain sensurure
seul, pour que les négociateurs
accélèrent le pas.ssssssssssssss
les corridors, eux, semblent
dire que les choses avancent
lentement mais sûrement,
mais certains craignen l l l l e
des ambitions pour arriver
à une conclusion.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada,